اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
روسيا تسقط مسيرات اوكرانيه فوق جزيره
القرم وتفرض حدودها من السكان بسبب القصف
الاوكراني
الجيش السوداني يؤكد ان مدينه كوتومبي
دارفور ما زالت تحت سيطرته بعد مواجهات مع
قوات الدعم
مصر واسرائيل تتفقان على زياده ابراج
وكاميرات المراقبه على الحدود بعد حادث
معبر العوجه
تجاره
وحركه المخدرات وزير الخارجيه العراقيه
يؤكد لنظيره السوري على اهميه التعاون لحل
ازمه اللاجئين والمخدرات بين البلدين
اذا مشاهدينا نبدا الخامسه من الملف
الروسي الاوكراني السلطات الروسيه دعت
سكان منطقه شبكينو في اقليم بيلجادور الى
مغادره منازلهم عقب اشتداد القصف
الاوكراني هذا الاسبوع حاكم المنطقه في
اجسلاف جلاد كوف حتى السكان على التعاون
مع السلطات واخلاء المنطقه ومغادره
منازلهم مؤقتا افاد بان المنطقه شهدت ليله
اخرى غير هادئه وايضا شهدت اضرار جسيمه
جراء القصف الاوكراني حيث قتلت امراتان
واصيب اخرون
احس القرى وخصوصا منطقه شبكينو التي تعرضت
للقصف على الاستماع لموقف السلطات
والمغادره مؤقتا من منازلهم من اجل الحفاظ
على اهم شيء وهو حياتهم وحياه المقربين
منهم
اذن العواجل تتحدث عن تسليم قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه للعراق 50 معتقل من داعش هذه
جزء من سلسله من العمليات للتسليم من هم
في معظمهم من مخيم ابو الهول طبعا مع
عائلاتهم نوافيكم بالمزيد من التفاصيل على
ورودها ونكمل من الملف الاوكراني الروسي
ومع تغيير كليب لتكتكتها العسكريه مؤخرا
حيث نقلت الحرب الى داخل العمق الروسي
تغيرت قواعد اللعبه اعلنت السلطات
المواليه لموسكو في شبه جزيره القرم اسقاط
التسع مسيرات اوكرانيه وذلك في مدينه
جانكوي التي تقع في الجزء الشمالي من شبه
الجزيره طبعا هذا الهجوم هو الاحدث في
سلسله هجمات كثافتها كييف مؤخرا هجمات
شملت استهداف مبنى الكرملين ووسط العاصمه
موسكو واخيرا استهداف من طاقات بالجورود
الروسيه شمالي الحدود مع اوكرانيا
في القرن قال ان الدفاعات الجويه استطاعت
ان تسقط خمس مسيرات اوكرانيه فيما قامت
وسائله اعلام حربيه الكترونيه بالسيطره
على اربع مسيرات اخرى الهجوم ادى الى تحطم
النوافذ في ثلاثه منازل وسيارتين نتيجه
تحطم احدى المسيرات طبعا شبه جزيره القرم
تعتبر هدف متكرر لاوكرانيا حيث تكتسب
اهميه استراتيجيه لموسكو وتعد مركز امداد
عسكري للقوات الروسيه رويترز تقول ان لدى
روسيا قاعده جويه عسكريه بالقرب من
دجانكوي حيث تحولت المدينه وايضا المناطق
المحيطه بها الى اكبر قاعده عسكريه لموسكو
في القرم
على كل المزيد ينضم الينا من مدينه
سيفاستوبول بشبه جزيره القرمو استاذ
العلوم السياسيه الدكتور عمار قناه اهلا
بك دكتور عمار بدايه قراءتك للمشهد واخر
التطورات الميدانيه وعندما نتحدث عن افراغ
لبعض المناطق على الحدود حجم هذا التحرك
الروسي وطبيعه الخطر التي الذي يواجه
روسيا بهذا الاطار
تحياتي
نعم هناك تحولات يعني ملموته في الواقع
يعني العسكري ومحاولات من ايف نقل الصراع
من مربع عسكري الى مربع اخر وهو يعني مبني
على خساره يعني الخساره الرمزيه والمعنويه
وايضا العسكريه لمدينه
يعني بعد سقوط هذه المدينه تم التوجه الى
تحرك حول او من خلال المسيرات الى العمق
الامريكي وهذه الهجمات يعني هي ليست وليده
الحاضر على مستوى يعني شبه جزيره القرم
ممكن القول
الدكتور عمار يعني انت بما معناه تقول انه
هي محافظه او بالاحرى محاوله لحفظ ماء
الوجه من قبل اوكرانيا ليست جديده ولكنها
لم تكن ابدا بهذه القوه وهذه الكثافه
سيدتي لم اقل يعني لحفظ ماء الوجه لكنها
يعني نقله مرتبطه يعني بالمعادله السياسيه
لا يمكننا اليوم ان نستثني يعني المسار
العسكري عن المسار السياسي وهو ما يتعلق
يعني بالمعادله الاقليميه والمعادله
الدوليه لطالما كانت مرتبطه يعني مساله
الصمود
وصمود يعني القوات الاوكرانيه في باص هو
كان بمثابه يعني الدعم الاساسي
اللي ممكن القول قوه السياسيه او
الدماغ يعني الاوروبي الاستمراريه الدعم
وتسليح اوكرانيا فاليوم يعني ننتقل الى
مرحله اخرى وهي انا اعتبرها بمثابه
الاستفزازات العسكريه لجر روسيا الى
مربعات اخرى او الوقوع في الخطا
الاستراتيجي
وبالتالي السؤال المطروح الان كيف يمكن
لروسيا ان ترد وبغض النظر عن ان ما كانت
رد فعل عما حدث بباخمت او لا الا تؤثر على
صوره روسيا بصوره عامه امام العالم وعلى
صوره روسيا وتحديدا الرئيس الروسي في
الداخل الروسي
سؤال مهم جدا سيدتي الكريمه باعتقد وكما
اراه من خلال يعني القراءات الاكاديميه
والعلميه وايضا يعني المجتمعيه ان كل هذه
الهجمات هي تعزز من شعبيه الاداره الروسيه
وخاصه شعبيه الرئيس بوتين هذه يعني هذا
الصراع هو لم يكن منذ البدايه بين روسيا
واوكرانيا بل هو ما بين روسيا والغرب
الجماعي
الارهابيه من خلال يعني استهداف المناطق
السكنيه وخاصه الحدوديه والتي تقلو من
المعسكرات يعني العسكريه او ما يمكن ان
توجه خطرا في اوكرانيا هذا دليل واضح يعني
للمجتمع الروسي بان فعلا هناك نقله اخرى
لكن روسيا لا تعتمد في سياستها يعني كانت
عسكريه او سياسيه على مبدا الفعل ورد
الفعل المباشر هناك اهداف يعني استراتيجيه
من خلال هذه اله جومات ولكن لا يمنع سيدي
انه التغير في التكتيكات التي شاهدناها
الان يمكن لها ان تغير من تعاطي روسيا مع
هذا الملف السؤال الان في ظل ما ذكرته من
ارتفاع الشعبيه في ظل ما تشهد روسيا الان
هل يدفع الرئيس الروسي اكثر للمواجهه
العسكريه اكثر واكثر وتغيير الاستراتيجيه
بهذا الاطار او لا الموضوع ربما يدفع
للعوده للحوار اذا كان الميدان بيده
سيدتي للوهله الاولى ممكن يعني التوافق
لكن اليوم يعني كل هذه التحركات لها ابعاد
سياسيه مدروسه من قبل الغرب وهي جر يعني
روسيا الى ما ابعد من ذلك لكن بما يتعلق
في الكرملين وهناك اهداف استراتيجيه واضحه
جدا للعمليه العسكريه الاستمراريه نرى ان
هناك تقدم ولا تراجع هناك اخفاقات وارتبات
في عمليه تسليح اوكرانيا تباين يعني واضح
في داخل الناتو والمنظومه الغربيه تجاه
الازمه غياب الحلول السياسيه والتوجه الى
الطرق الدبلوماسيه غير مطروحه اليوم في
الغرب هذا كله يعني ياتي ضمن يعني منظومه
الحاليه التي نراها وهي مساله الاستنزاف
استنزاف جميع الاطراف والسؤال هنا يعني
المهم في هذه المرحله من سيقدر يعني على
الاستمراريه نرى ان هناك تفاقمات
وارتدادات لهذه العمليات العسكريه
ارتدادتها الاقتصاديه وال جيو السياسيه
والاستقباضات في الداخل الاوروبي والداخل
الامريكي نحن اليوم امام النقله او مرحله
اخرى من هذا الصراع ولا اعتقد انه سيكون
ايجابيا بالمنظومه
بشبه جزيره القرمو استاذ العلوم السياسيه
دكتور عمار قناه شكرا جزيلا لك
يبدو ان الرد الروسي على هذه الضربات
الاوكرانيه لم يتاخر اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه توجيه ضربه وصفتها عاليه الدقه
وايضا بعيده المدى على اهداف في المطارات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه المتحدث باسم الوزاره
اشار الى اصابه مراكز القياده ونقاط
الرادار ومعدات الطيران الاوكرانيه وكذلك
منشات تخزين بالاسلحه والذخيره كما طالت
الضربه ورشه لتجميع المسيرات الاوكرانيه
باسلحه عاليه الدقه في احدى المقاطعات
الى ملف السوداني الان شهدت مدينه كوتون
في شمال دارفور شهدت مواجهات اسفلت عن
مقتل مدنيين ياتي ذلك فيما نفى الجيش
السوداني سيطره الدعم السريع على المدينه
وقد اظهرت مقاطع مصوره حصلت عليها العربيه
اظهرت تصاعدا كثيفا لاعمده الدخان مع
استمرار الاشتباكات في شوارع المدينه وسط
مخاوف من اتساع الصراع وتحوله الى اقتتال
قبلي من جانبه اعلن حاكم دارفور من اركوم
الناوي الاقليم منطقه منكوبه مع استمرار
اعمال النهب والقتل مشيرا الى ان المدنيين
يتعرضون في مدينتي كتم ولجنينه الانتهاكات
مروعه
[موسيقى]
هذا هو تواصلت الاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في عده مناطق
داخل العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم طبعا مع
تركيزها في شمالي مدينه الخرطوم بحري هذه
الاشتباكات تزامنت مع قصف جوي نفذه سلاح
الجو السوداني على المدينه مصحوبا بقصف
مدفعي من قاعدته وافاد سكان ام درمان
بسماع اصوات اطلاق نار وذوي اسلحه خفيفه
ومتوسطه مع تحليق لطيران الاستطلاع
والمروحيات في سماء المدينه التي تشهد
انقطاعا للتيار الكهربائي جراء المواجهات
وقد اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع اسقاط طائره
حربيه من طراز مايك تابعه للجيش السوداني
وذلك بعد هجوم طيران الجيش على مواقع
تمركز قوات الدعم السريع في منطقه بحر قال
المتحدث باسم الدعم السريع في بيان على
تويتر انه تم التصدي للهجوم باسقاط
الطائره مشيرا الى وقوع ضحايا في صفوف
القوات دون ذكر تفاصيل
على كل للمزيد معنا من الخرطوم مع صحفي
عمار ابو شيبه اهلا بك عمار اخر التطورات
الميدانيه تفضل
اهلا بك ميسون واهلا بالمشاهدين الكرام
نعم ميسون اخر التطورات الميدانيه هنا في
شرق العاصمه الخرطوم وفي جنوب العاصمه
الخرطوم قبل نصف ساعه من الان كنا نستمع
لعدد من ذوي
الانفجارات هنا في جنوب العاصمه الخرطوم
ويمكن للصوره ايضا ان توضح عدد من الحرائق
التي تدور بالقرب من المنطقه واعمده
الدخان تتصاعد بشكل كثيف جراء هذه
الانفجارات وهذه المنطقه ميسون هي
بالتحديد في جنوب العاصمه
الخرطوم هي قريبه من المدينه الرياضيه
التي دارت فيها الاشتباكات في اليوم الاول
في الخامس عشر من ابريل الماضي هذه
الاعمده التي تتصاعد ميسون منذ
اكثر من نصف ساعه من الدخول لهذا المباشر
ان نشاهدها وتتصاعد بهذا الشكل المكثف
اللي عده حرائق عده مناطق ربما هي اهدافا
على الارض وربما مباني وربما ايضا
مستودعات
حتى هذه اللحظه لم نتاكد بشكل مباشر ما
ماذا يدور في هذه المنطقه ولكن كنا نستمع
الى ذوي الانفجارات العنيف في هذه المنطقه
في جنوب العاصمه
الخرطومه الصوره الان تتحدث ميسون بشكل
واضح وتوضح هذه المشاهد
الان ايضا نستمع الى انفجار جديد
قد تسمع وبعد نصف ساعه لنستطيع معرفه
تفاصيل اليس هناك من نداءات خاصه نشاهد ان
هناك اكثر من مبنى سكني محيط في تلك
المنطقه ماذا عن القاتنين هناك ام انها
مناطق فارغه ربما اخلاها سكانها
نعم ربما هي مناطق ليس فيها عدد من السكان
لاننا لم نرصد عمليات استغاثه او مناشدات
الخروج من هذه المنطقه ولكن منطقه جنوب
العاصمه الخرطوم والمدينه الرياضيه التي
تجاور هذا الحريق وعده حرائق اخرى تظهر من
خلال هذا المشهد يبدو واضحا فيها ميسون ان
ليس هنالك من السكان في هذه المنطقه المهم
في هذه الصوره ان هذه المنطقه كانت قد جرت
فيها عده مناوشات وعده اهداف عسكريه تم
قصفها من خلال سلاح الجو السوداني في
الايام الماضيه وكانت ترد قوات الدعم
السريع بعدد من المضادات الارضيه نعم كان
معنا من الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه شكرا جزيلا
لك
وايضا فيما يتعلق بالتطورات في دارفور
معنى من هناك الصحفي صالح ابو علامه اهلا
بك استاذ صالح اخر التطورات الميدانيه
تفضل
اهلا بك مرحبا بجميع المشاهدين في هذه
اللحظات وصل درحه مدينه كتم الى مستشفى
الفاشر بغرض تلقي العلاج الوضع في مدينه
الاوضاع الانسانيه هناك اوضاع سيئه للغايه
بعد عمليات التي تعرضت لها مدينه كتم من
قصف ومعارك دارت بين الجيش والدعم السريع
لا زالت مستمره حتى اللحظه سيد صالح
هنالك يعني بعض الجهاد في مدينه بها اطلاق
للنار وبها ايضا تبادل
للنار الانباء الوارده من هناك تشير الى
انتشار واسع جدا لقوات الدعم السريع في
هذه المدينه ومدينه كتب هي المدينه
الثانيه بعد عاصمه الولايه مدينه الفاشل
وهي مدينه كبيره بها ايضا قياده كبيره
للجيش للدعم السريع هناك انتشار عذرا فقط
للتوضيح لانه في نفي من قبل الجيش
السوداني ان تكون قوات الدعم السريع قد
سيطرت على المدينه هناك انتشار واسع ولكن
لا سيطره كامله هذا ما تقوله
نعم حتى يعني حتى صباح اليوم الاخبار
الوارده من هناك تشير الى سيطره قوات
الدعم السريع على المدينه وعلى قياده
الجيش هناك لكن بيان الجيش وضحا وقال بان
المدينه لم تسقط في يد الدعم السريع يعني
كان يعني المعارك بين الجيش والدعم في في
عدد مواقع تدور يحدث انتشار واسع للدعم
الشريع وبعد ذلك يرجع الجيش بعد المناطق
وتظل عمليات القر والفر موجوده في عده
مناطق سكنيه سيد صالح وبالمقابل اخر محصله
فيما يتعلق بالضحايا
نعم حتى الان هنالك حصيله تقول بان
الضحايا الذين سقطوهم يعني 54 قتيل حتى
الان عدد منهم من معسكر كساب وهو معسكر
للنازحين بمدينه كتم يعني هذا المعسكر
تعرض لقصف وتعرض
لنيران كثيفه نسبه لانه واقع يعني قريب من
مرمى النيران اكبر منطقه شهدت قتل
للنازحين هي منطقه كتب في المعرفه التي
دارت بين الجيش والدعم السريع ولازلنا
نتحدث عن معركه ما بين
هذين الطرفين ولكن هناك مخاوف من ان تتوسع
المعارك لتصبح قبليه كيف
معرفه
هذه
من يحلل ما دار هناك يؤول الى قتل بعض
قوات الجيش في الاسبوع الماضي وهو ايضا
يتبع لاحدى المكونات بمدينه كتم ربما هذا
الامر هو من فاقم يعني عمليات العراق
وعمليات القتال اكثر لذا يتخوف يعني الناس
هنا المعارك التي تدور بين الجيش والدعم
السريع نسبه لان القبائل هنا لديها ابناء
في الجيش ولديها ابناء في الدعم السريع
وكثيرا ما نرى عندما
اصوات الرصاص نرى مواطنين يذهبون الى يعني
مقرات الجيش حمايه لابنائهم ونرى ايضا
مواطنين يذهبون الى مواقع الدعم السريع
لحاقا بابنائهم في قياده الدعم السريع
يعني الخير هنا في دارفور عندما تبدا
المعرفه ياخذ منحى اخر لذا يتخوف كثير من
الناس من تحول الى صراع اهلي خاصه مع
انتشار السلاح شكرا جزيلا لك من اقليم
دارفور الصحفي صالح ابو علامه على هذه
المعلومات وطبعا نعود للصور التي نشاهدها
على الهواء مباشره صور مباشره مشاهدينا
للدخان يتصاعد من قلب العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم هناك تجدد للاشتباكات بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني في اكثر من
نقطه هذه النقطه وان تجددت فيها
الاشتباكات والقصف والدخان بدا منذ حوالي
النصف ساعه من بدا هذه النشره الى الدخان
لازال مستمر وكانت هذه المنطقه قد استهدفت
وهي قريبه من الملعب الرياضي قد استهدفت
في وقت سابق
هذا وقد دعى الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي للاطراف السودانيه الى تغليب
الحكمه والوقوف الفوري لاطلاق النار جاء
ذلك خلال مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع الرئيس
الموريتاني محمد ولد الشيخ في القاهره
تشعرنا كذلك بشان التطورات الاوضاع في
السودان واكدنا اهميه التوقف الفوري
والمستدام لاطلاق النار والحفاظ على
المؤسسات الوطنيه السودانيه ومنعها من
الانهيار وتكثيف الجهود لنفاذ المساعدات
الانسانيه والاغاثيه العاجله للتخفيف من
معاناه المتضررين ومن هذا المنبر فاننا
نحس جميع الاطراف على تغليب صوت الحكمه
للحفاظ على مقدرات الدوله السودانيه
ومصالح شعبها
هذا هو منذ اندلاع الصراع في السودان
انتشرت عمليات نهب وسرقه على نطاق واسع
شامله الاسواق التجاريه امتدت حتى للمقر
الحكوميه وايضا الوزارات ما وضع المواطن
السوداني امام واقع صعب طبعا في ظل تبادل
الاتهامات بين طرفي الصراع المتابع
لاستثناء سواء في ام درمان او في ولايات
ومدن السودان الاخرى عمليات سرقه ونهب لم
تفرق بين محل تجاريه او مقر حكوميه
[موسيقى]
التربيه والتعليم بجنوب دارفور عمليات
تخريب شملت حرقا كاملا لمخازن الوزاره
ومطابع الامتحانات الوحيده التي تقدم
الخدمات ايضا لولايتي شرق ووسط دارفور
المؤسف ايضا تم حرق كل المطابع تاعتنا
التي نطبع بها الامتحانات التي نضع بها
الامتحانات للمراحل المختلفه
وبنضع بها ايضا لاخواننا في وسط دارفور
ونضع بها لاخواننا في شركه دارفور حادثه
من بين مجموعه حلت بالسودانيين كانت وراء
تعليق ولايه جنوب دارفور العام الدراسي
واغلاق المدارس لاجل غير مسمى وهو من عكس
على حياه السودانيين فلا خدمات سواء صحيه
او تعليميه فيما يعجز التجار عن تقدير حتى
خسائرهم الفادحه نتيجه النهب ويبقى
المواطن السوداني اسيرا لكل هذه الازمات
في الخامسه ولكن بعد
قليل الهند ترجعوا كارثه القطاريين الى
خلل في نظام الاشارات
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه وكما
قبل الفاصل كان هناك صور مباشره تاتينا من
الخرطوم نعود لننقل تكمله لهذه الصور حيث
الدخان لازال يتصاعد حتى هذه اللحظه جراء
تبادل للقسمه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع اشتباكات بدات قبل حوالي
النصف الساعه من بدء هذه النشره كان معنى
مراسل العربيه
لينقل لنا الصوره مباشره وهذه صور ايضا
مباشره لاستمرار تصاعد الدخان من عدد من
المناطق في وسط الخرطوم طبعا هذه المنطقه
قال مراسلنا في حينها انها ليست للمره
الاولى التي يتم استهدافها خلال بث مباشر
على الهواء قبل حوالي الربع ساعه من الان
كان هناك ايضا استمرار لسماع عدوي بعض
الانفجارات وان كانت المتقطعه اذن
مشاهدينا نتابع هذه الصور المباشره
لاستمرار تصاعد الدخان فيما يعود الى عوده
وتجدد للاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع في العاصمه الخرطوم كان
هناك ايضا اعلان من قبل قوات الدعم السريع
سابقا عن اسقاط طائره حربيه من طراز ميك
تابعه للجيش السوداني بعد هجوم طيران
الجيش على مواقع تقول القوات قوات الدعم
السريعه انها تتمركز فيها في منطقه بحري
طبعا مشاهدينا لمن يريد متابعه التطورات
الميدانيه بتفاصيلها في السودان يمكنه
متابعه ذلك وايضا الصور المباشره من
الخرطوم على الحدث
ولمن بقي معي من المتابعين طبعا نكمل من
بولندا حيث شارك حوالي نصف مليون بولندي
في تظاهره ضد الحكومه في شوارع وارسو هي
الاكبر منذ 30 عاما وفقا لمنظميها تدفق
المحتجون من جميع انحاء هولندا استجابه
لدعوه لحزب المنصه المدنيه المعارض
للاحتجاج ان كان على غلاء المعيشه او
للدعم الديمقراطيه وايضا الانتخابات الحره
والاتحاد الاوروبي رفع المحتجون لافتات
كتب عليها يكفي وذلك ضد الحزب الحاكم
في اعقاب هجوم معبر العوجه الحدودي في مصر
افادت مصادره العربيه بان مصر واسرائيل
اتفقتى على زياده كاميرات وابراج المراقبه
على الحدود قبل ذلك دعت اسرائيل السلطات
المصريه للتعاون في فتح تحقيق شامل ومشترك
حول الحادثه التي ادت لمقتل ثلاثه جنود
اسرائيليين على يد عنصر امن مصري قتله
الجيش الاسرائيلي لاحقا قال رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو ان اسرائيل
بعثت برساله للحكومه المصريه بشان التحقيق
المشترك متعهدا باجراءات لمنع وقوع هجمات
مماثله والحد من عمليات التهريب
الحديثه على الحدود المصريه كانت خطيره
وغير عاديه وسيتم التحقيق بشانها بشكل
دقيق اسرائيل وجهت رساله واضحه للحكومه
المصريه نتوقع ان يكون التحقيق المشترك
شاملا وفقا لتعاون الامني المهم بيننا سوف
نستخلص كل الاستنتاجات اللازمه فيما يتعلق
باعمالنا على طول السياج الحدودي الجنوبي
على الحدود الاسرائيليه المصريه
معبر العوجه نتسانا الحدودي بين اسرائيل
ومصر انشئ عام
1982 عقب معاهده السلام بين اسرائيل ومصر
على بعد اربعين كيلو مترا من نقطه التقاء
الحدود الاسرائيليه المصريه شرق رفح
استخدم في بدايته معبرا للمسافرين
والمركبات ويستخدم حاليا لاستيراد البضائع
من مصر الى اسرائيل او قطاع غزه
في عام 2012 بنت اسرائيل سياجا امنيا على
طول الحدود بطول 241 كيلومترا من ايلات
وطاب على البحر الاحمر حتى نقطه التقاء
الحدود المصريه الاسرائيليه
نوفمبر 2022 تاريخ اخر محاوله تسلل شهدتها
الحدود المصريه الاسرائيليه قتل خلالها
احد المهربين
وفي الثالث من يونيو من عام 2023 مقتل
ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين على الحدود مع مصر
المزيد معنا من القدس المحلي السياسي الي
نيسان ومعنى من القاهره دكتور سمير غطاس
رئيس منتدى الشرق الاوسط للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه وابدا بما يتعلق بالتصريحات
بصوره عامه فيما شاهدناه يبدو ان الطرفين
اسرائيل ومصر
اتفقا على الاقل فيما يتعلق بالتنسيق
الامني هناك توافق بهذا الاطار ولكن ماذا
عن ردود الفعل وابدا معك دكتور سمير اهلا
بك كيف تقرا ردود الفعل الاسرائيليه وهل
عرضت الجانب المصرفي طرحها
يعني انا اعتقد ان جزء كبير من ردود الفعل
الاسرائيليه موجه للداخل الاسرائيلي وليس
الى مصر لان هناك اخفاقات اسرائيليه عديده
فيما يتعلق بالقدره على الانذار بصرف
النظر عن الدوافع التي هي محل تحقيق فان
جندي استطاع ان يخترق الاجراءات الامنيه
الاسرائيليه يدخل الى الداخل يقتل اثنين
من الاسرائيليين الجنود اسرائيل اكتشفت
جثه الجنديين بعد ليس اقل من ساعتين ثم
اختبا في مكان وجاءت قوه اخرى هناك يعني
خلل اخر هو ان القوه الجديده التي جاءت
لتشتبك مع هذا الشاب المتسلل لم تحضر
ومعها غطاء جوي حتى من الهليكوبتر استطاع
هو ان يجتمع وقتل واصابه اخرين وبالتالي
قيل بان هناك نوع من التقصير ولكن فيما
يتعلق بردود الفعل وان كان الرساله داخليه
البعض راى انه كيفيه التعاطي مع هذا الملف
كان فيها نوع من التحريض على الاقل على
المستوى الاعلامي وايضا على المستوى
العسكري هل هذا ايضا لا يعني الجانب
المصري حكومه
وبالتالي يجب وضعه جانبا فيما يتعلق
بالعلاقه بين الجانبين
يعني مصر التزمت بالبيان الذي صدر عن
وزاره الدفاع ولم يصدر اي تعليقات اخرى
غير رسميه الجانب الاسرائيلي هناك عديد من
التصريحات بعضها غير لائق على الاطلاق
يعني الاتهام بانه البيان المصري مهيب
يعني سخيف الى اخر هذه الالات السخيفه انا
اعتقد ان اعضاء كنيست واعلاميين
اسرائيليين اساؤوا كثيرا في التصريحات قبل
ان يتم التحقيق في المجرى هذا الامر يسيء
للعلاقه الاسرائيليه التي هي بارده
بطبيعتها ايضا يضاف الى محل من قبل
نتنياهو بانه هذا عمل ارهابي وايضا خطير
وهنا انقل السؤال لاليه حول هذه النقطه
تحديدا في قضيه التعاطي وان كانت داخليه
هناك من ربما خرج عن السياق العام في
التعاطي مع هذا الملف الى اي حد معنيه
اسرائيل بالحفاظ على علاقتها مع مصر على
حساب حربها الداخلي ه اذا ما صح التعبير
اولا
ارحب بكم ارحب السيد سمير بهذا الموضوع
وعلى عده ملاحظات لما قاله سمير
اولا فعلا
الانتقادات موجهه الى المستوى العسكري في
اسرائيل وان كان هناك تخادل وكان هناك
تقصيرات في اداء العديد من الضباط في
المنطقه الجنوبيه واعتقد ان بعد ان يقدم
المحقق بهذا الموضوع خلال الاسبوع القادم
حسب ما طلب به رئيس اركان جيش الدفاع
اعتقد ان العديد من الضباط سيتم تنحيتهم
من هذا من منصبهم ثانيا ليس هناك الي اسمح
لي ليس هناك من رضا عما طرح من قبل هؤلاء
العسكريين لانه يؤثر على العلاقه مع مصر
وكان فيها ربما انقل كلمات ضيف استخفاف
بردود الفعل المصريه والبيان المصري انا
ارد على على اقوال سيد سمير ولكن اذا
تسمحي لي انا اقول ان العلاقات الاستر
اتيجيه بين اسرائيل وبين مصر هي علاقات
مهمه
ودليل على ذلك ان
انا ارفض ما قله السيد سمير لم تكن هناك
انتقادات للجهات للجانب المصري وانما كانت
انتقادات للبيان الذي صدر عن مصر لان لا
يمكن ان الشخص الذي قام بهذا بهذه الفعله
يقوم كما قال
الناطق بلسان الجيش المصري او الحكومه
المصريه لم يكن تبادل اطلاق النار تماما
وما فحصوا البنادق للجنديين الاولين الذي
قتلان مفاجاههم انا انا يوم امس كتبت في
الفيسبوك انه لا يعقل ان جند مجند او مجند
ياتون الى
نوبه نوبه حراسه لمده اكثر من 12 ساعه حتى
اذا يكون اكبر بطل في العالم لا يمكن انه
لا يف قد من يقظاته بهذا الموضوع ثانيا
كما قلت العلاقات بين اسرائيل وبين مصر هي
علاقات مهمه ولكن فيها تشكيك اليه من
الحديث الذي طرحته هناك تشكيك بالروايه
رغم انه التحقيق لم يبدا اولا وبالتالي لا
يمكن القفز حتى النهايه وماذا لو صدقت
الروايه المصريه بالنهايه لاحظت امتعادك
دكتور عندما علق على هذه النقطه تحديدا
ماذا تقول صحيح
يعني لا يمكن الفصل ما بين اتهام او
الاساءه لتهام لبيان القوات المسلحه وانه
لم يوجه اتهاما للنظام البيان صادر عن عن
وزاره الدفاع عندما يقول عضو كنيسه ان هذا
البيان مهين وسخيف فهذا امر غير مقبول من
الجانب المصري لكن اننا كشعب ولا حتى من
المسؤولين ان اتحدث بصفته مواطن ومحلل
سياسي هذا امر غير مقبول ان يقال عن بيان
صادر من القوات المسلحه انه سخيف ومهين
هذه مساله غير مقبوله هذه لغه غير مقبوله
اذا تعود الاسرائيلين ان يتحدث عما احد
بهذه اللغه فهذا لا يليق مثل الحديث مع
مصر اذا كان هناك متهم في في يجب التحقيق
معاه في 16/7 اسمحيلي بس اقول هذه المساله
لانها في غايه الاهميه في في عندهم في
اسرائيل صحفي محلل مهم جدا اسمه يوسي
ميلمان يوسي ملما في
16/7/2022 كشف النقاب بموافقه الرقابه
العسكريه عن مج 80 جندي مصري تم دفنهم تحت
حديقه الان قتل منهم عشرين بالحرق يعني
لدينا 80 مصري اذا حد متهم فهو الجيش
الاسرائيلي فهو الدوله الاسرائيليه فهو
المؤسسه الاسرائيليه فهو المحللين
الاسرائيليين نحن في مصر لا يمكن ان نقبل
مثل هذا السلام اذا كانت هناك يجب ان تكون
هناك لغه راقيه لا يمكن استخدام لغه مثل
مهين الى اخر هذه المجال للرد لانه لم يعد
لدي وقت دكتور سمير ووصلت الرساله
غير منصف وانا اطلب ان ارد على كل ما قاله
الوقت
باختصار باختصار
لا لا السيد سمير اسمع كلامي كن مؤدب اولا
كلامي
لم يخرج عن نطاق ما تم نقله
وطرح طرح نقاط رئيسيه تم طرحها من قبل
صحفي اسرائيلي تفضل
اولا احد في حكومه اسرائيل لن يستعمل كلمه
سخيف وانا اسف على ما تقوله ربما قالوا
خليني خليني ارد لا تقاطعني
قالوا ان البيان هو خير واقعي وصحيح انه
البيان هو غير واقعي لان لا يمكن انه
الجيش المصري او الحكومه المصريه تربط بين
التجار المخدرات الذين تم القاء القبض او
على هذه الكميه وبين ما حدث في ساعه
الساعه السادسه
والنصفيه الرسميه وهذا شيء خطير ما تنقله
هو ما يعكس الموقف الرسمي الاسرائيلي او
قراءتك للمشهد ما عليه
لازم اقاطعك لانه تصريحات خطيره تشكيك
بالروايه المصريه الرسميه اتفضل
اسرائيل قالت ان الخبر او البيان كان غير
دقيق وليس كما قال سمير انه سخيف احد لا
يستعمل بكلمه
عندي النص
كلمات كلمات
بكل ما قاله
صحفي المخدرة حتى تعلم يا سمير انه في حرب
في حرب 73 عندما عندما دخل كاميرا هناك
قوات مصريه التي دخلت الى الحدود
الاسرائيليه بهدف محاوله
صحح معلوماتك 67
في حينها وبالتالي علي ان هن انهي هذا
النقاش الى نيسان المحلل السياسي كان معنا
من القدس ومن القاهره الدكتور سمير غطاس
رئيس منتدى الشرق الاوسط للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه
انتهى الوقت شكرا لك
على هامش زياره يقوم بها وزير الخارجيه
السوري فيصل المقداد الى بغداد اكد وزير
الخارجيه العراقي فؤاد حسين انه نسق مع
نظيره السوري سبل مكافحه تهريب المخدرات
من والى البلدين
هذا اليوم ايضا قضيه كيفيه العمل المشترك
بين العراق وسوريا
لمحاربه تجاره
وحركه المخدرات
من المعلوم ان
العراق
ممر
لهذه الحركه ولكن ايضا
ومع الاسف انه بدا ايضا استهلاك المخدرات
في المجتمع العراقي
وزير الخارجيه العراقيه اكد ايضا على
ضروره التدخل الاقليمي والدولي لمعالجه
ملف الوضع الانساني المتدهور في سوريا
مشيرا الى اهميه التعاون لحل ازمه
اللاجئين السوريين
انسان في سوريا وضع صعب جدا
ونحتاج الى تحرك تحرك على المستوى
الاقليمي
طبعا مستوى ثنائي لكن ايضا اقليمي ودولي
قضيه اللاجئين السوريين ايضا جزء مهم من
هذه المساله ومن هذه المشكله كيفيه
التعامل مع اللاجئين السوريين
وخاصه اللاجئين موجودين في الدول المحيطه
في لبنان في الاردن
[موسيقى]
من جانبه قال وزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل
المقداد قال ان بلاده تدين ما وصفه
بالاعتداءات التركيه التي تطالوا بلاده
والعراق ودعا الى ضروره وقف دعم التنظيمات
الارهابيه المتواجده في سوريا
نحن ضد الاعتداءات التي تتم سواء داخل
الاراضي العراقيه وندين هذه الاعتداءات
ونطالب بوقفها او الدعم الذي يقدم
للمجموعات الارهابيه المسلحه في بعض
المناطق في سوريا وخاصه
لجبهه النصره ول11 كما ذكرت هذا يجب ان
يتوقف
وستكون له تفاعلات كثيره
اذا
استمر لان البلدين قادرين على التنسيق
فيما بينهما بينهما لمواجهات هذه التحديات
هذا وقال وزير السكك الحديد الهندي ان
حادث خروج قطارين عن مسارهما في شرق
البلاد نتج عن خلل في نظام الاشارات
الالكترونيه ما ادى الى تغيير مسار قطار
بشكل خاطئ الحادث الذي يعد الاسوا منذ
عقود ادى لمقتل اكثر من 300 شخص واصابه
مئات اخرين
وادي عوده مشاهدينا الى الصور التي تاتينا
مباشره من داخل العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
وتصاعد للدخان لا زال مستمر وان خفت وطاته
حتى الان بدا قبل نصف ساعه من بدء النشره
حوالي
ساعه من الان تقريبا بدا هناك نوع من
المواجهات والاشتباكات بين قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني في تلك المنطقه
وايضا مناطق اخرى من وسط العاصمه الخرطوم
حرائق متفرقه جنوب الخرطوم بسبب هذه
الاشتباكات طبعا المزيد على الحدث ولكن
نحن الان نكمل الخامسه
وفي الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
تحركات بالكونغرس الامريكيه لتجديد القيود
على تكنولوجيا الذكاء الاصطناعي
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه بعد حادثتين
بين قوات البلدين في الايام الاخيره في
مضيق تايوان وبحر الصين الجنوبي ندد
الفينتاجون بما وصفه بالتصرفات الخطيره
للجيش الصيني في منطقه اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ المتحدث باسم البنتاجون باترا قال
ان بلاده لا تزال تشعر بقلق ايذاء الانشطه
الخطره بشكل متزايد للجيش الصيني بالمنطقه
من جهته قال وزير الدفاع الصيني لشانغ فو
ان عقليه الحرب البارده عادت للظهور في
منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ لكن بلاده تسعى
للحوار وليس للمواجهه حذر الوزير الصيني
من ان المواجهه بين بلاده وامريكا ستكون
كارثه لا يمكن للعالم ان يتحملها
عقليه الحرب البارده عادت الى الظهور
وتزيد بشكل كبير من مخاطر المواجهه بين
الحلفاء والاعداء بعض القوى الكبرى تصر
على تطبيق ما تسميها باستراتيجيه المحيطين
الهندي والهادئ الصين ترى انه لا ينبغي
تطبيق اي استراتيجيه على اسس ايديولوجيه
او بناء اي تحالفات عسكريه بسبب تهديدات
وهميه لان هذا يمكن ان يؤدي الى توقعات
عسكريه انانيه ومتحيزه
لكن مشاهدينا لماذا تصاعدت حده التوترات
بين واشنطن وبيكين خلال الفتره الاخيره
السبب يعودوا الى تراكم الخلافات من
ابرزها وطبعا وفق خبراء تايوان وبحر الصين
الجنوبي والقيود التي فرضها الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن على صادرات الرقائق
اشباه الموصلات الى الصين ففي الوقت الذي
تكثف فيه الصين من ضغوطها العسكريه
والسياسيه لاجبار الجزيره على قبول
متطلبات بكين بالسياده والتي ترفضها طبعا
حكومه بشده توسع الولايات المتحده من
انشطتها حول المحيطين الهندي والهادئ
لمواجهه مطالبات الصين وزير الدفاع
الامريكي اوستن تعهد بان واشنطن لن تؤيد
ما وصفه بالترهيب الصيني لحلفائها بل تفضل
الحوار على الصراع
ذكاء الاصطناعي تطور بشكل سريع وربما مخيف
ايضا حيث تتزايد المخاوف من تاثيرات
التكنولوجيا الحديثه على البشر هذه
المخاوف دفعت مجموعه من المشرعين
الديمقراطيين بالكونغرس الامريكيه لوضع
ضوابط قانونيه على الذكاء الاصطناعي كشف
موقع عن اخر خطط للنائب الديمقراطي ريتشى
توريس لتفعيل قانون يجبروا صناعه
تكنولوجيا الذكاء الاصطناعي وضع شاره تؤكد
ان المنتج ليس صناعه بشريه سيطلب مشروع
القانون من مصممي روبوتات الدردشه كشات جي
بي تي الحصول على اخلاء مسؤوليه لاعلام
المستخدمين بما قد ينطوي عليه من جوانب
سلبيه جراءه لاستخدام سيكون هذا المشروع
وهو اخر حلقه في سلسله جهود الكونجرس
للتاكد من ان التقدم التكنولوجي لا يسبب
اضرارا اجتماعيه بحسب السينات فان اعلان
اخلاء المسؤوليه يعتبر نقطه انطلاق جيده
للحد من مخاطر الذكاء الاصطنا عي لكنه ليس
بالحل السحري
بحسب رايه
بهذا نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه الخامسه
نلتقي غدا وخامسه جديده مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات